- [Mark] All right, Frankie.
Frankie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- Ohio.
- [Interviewer] Ohio?
What city?
- [Frankie] Cleveland.
- [Mark] Cleveland?
And how long have you been in LA?
or California?
- California, 20 years.
- [Mark] 20 years.
- LA, about eight months.
- [Mark] Were are you married?
- No.
- Never married.
- Do you have kids?
- No kids.
- [Mark] No kids.
And what do you do for a living?
- I manage restaurants
and I did construction.
- [Mark] Okay.
You like to come down here to skid row
and pick up some of the ladies sometimes?
- Yeah, I do.
Come down from Santa Monica
and that's pretty much
a place to come down.
It's inexpensive
and if I have one drink
and maybe pick up some drugs,
mainly for ladies I don't
really do drugs anymore
but I have in the past.
- [Mark] And you like to drink?
- Yes, I'm an alcoholic.
- Tell me about your childhood.
You had a good childhood?
- Nope.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
(sniffs loudly)
- Well, the only good thing
I can say about my childhood
is I wasn't ever abused
but my mom died when I was six.
She was 36 years old
and my dad died at 46
and I was 12.
So I pretty much raised myself
and then I lived with a sister who was 21.
She tried to raise me.
I went to college for a couple of years.
I held down some good jobs
but as far as childhood,
yeah, it wasn't good.
No abuse, no beatings.
I've seen much worse
or something like that.
I just had parents who died too early.
- [Mark] No, that's tragic.
- Yep.
- Twice.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
that has impacted your life?
- Oh yeah.
- [Mark] To this day?
- Yep.
- [Mark] In what ways do you think?
(clears throat)
- I had seven older brothers and sisters.
Three sisters are dead.
- [Mark] Here you go.
- Thank you.
Two brothers died.
(sniffles) Everybody before they were 50.
So I just thought
I was destined to die.
So I lived my life kind of recklessly.
Actually, I've had good jobs,
nice places to live,
good cars.
Then sometimes the wheels fall off
then I resort to my bad self.
- [Mark] Which is usually drinking?
- Yeah, drinking mainly.
- [Mark] Thank you for sharing that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's terrible.
- Yeah, I have done a
lot of drugs in the past
but not in the last couple of years.
- [Mark] Did you go to college?
- Yes, I did.
I graduated from high
school in Massachusetts
and I got accepted to Harvard
and I actually went through Harvard.
Unfortunately it was in
the back of a police car.
(both laugh)
But then after I got out, then
I actually went to college
in UMass Amherst
and I was doing really well
studying broadcast communication.
I was a radio DJ.
We had our own station out there.
It only broadcasted to like
half the campus (sniffs).
I'm trying to think of what
my DJ name was, but anyway,
(sniffs) that escapes me.
But then I came out here
for a two month vacation,
visited my brother up in Santa Cruz,
fell in love with a girl
and unfortunately didn't
go back finish college.
And this was in the eighties,
and back then you didn't think
you really needed college.
If I have my advice for anybody,
get an education,
get a trade, stay in school.
You won't end up a fool.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] So you come down here
to visit the ladies sometimes, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how's that go for you?
You know, I've heard all kinds of stories.
I've heard stories of
girls robbing the guys.
I've heard stories of guys
getting rough with the girls
or robbing them,
all kinds of stuff.
- Well, what I usually look for is,
I can usually tell in her face
or interactions
and I'm pretty careful.
And I've actually met a couple girls
in a bar or in a park
and they kind of turned
me on to someplace safe.
So when I come down here there's only
maybe two or three girls that I look for.
If I don't see 'em then I leave.
- [Mark] These are your regulars.
- Yep.
- [Mark] And you trust them?
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
And usually, like I said, if I get drugs
I give them to them because
I don't do drugs anymore, so.
But you know, it's all a barter system.
Everything is for sale down here.
- [Mark] Right.
So you guys would go to
the car, you go to a hotel,
where do you guys go?
- Well, I'm from Santa Monica.
I used to drive down here.
Unfortunately I had my car repossessed.
I still do have a place in Santa Monica.
And I, when I come down here,
I take the train and the bus down here
and I usually come down
here like once a week
and I see some people down here.
And it's a little bit easier
to access services down here.
- [Mark] Yeah, easy to get around.
- Yep.
- [Mark] Do you ever feel
like you would prefer a committed
relationship, a marriage,
something like that?
- Too old for that.
- [Mark] Too old for that?
- Yep.
- [Mark] And you like
the freedom and variety
that this provides?
- Yep.
Well, because I used to
have, you know it all,
a nice place, a nice job
but it was called responsibility.
And you know, now I don't have anything.
I don't have any responsibility.
Not saying that's good.
I don't like living on the street,
but at the same time (sniffs)
I don't have the problem with
an employer,
showing up for a job (sniffs),
a girlfriend
and I can do what I like
to do, which is drink.
- [Mark] And you usually get drunk
before you pick up the girls.
- Always, yeah.
- Always (laughs)
- Yeah (sniffs).
And I always gotta check to
make sure they're not a guy, so.
- [Mark] Oh, has that happened before?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
You can usually tell by the Adam's Apple
but then sometimes it's, you know,
there were some that
looked pretty much like
a woman (sniffs) so.
- [Mark] What's the most
and least you've paid
for a girl out here?
- Oh, I've paid like a
six pack of beer (sniffs)
and probably the most,
when I had money, $200,
but that was an error.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I was in Vegas.
- [Mark] Different neighborhood.
- Yeah, yeah, different place,
different lifestyle
- [Mark] This is the least
expensive you'll find?
- Oh yeah, that's why I come down here.
Oh, I can go down to Santa Monica
but they're gonna be 50 bucks down there.
(sniffs) I can come down here,
there's a couple I know 10 bucks
or I'd bring down some food
and a, you know, a bottle of wine,
you know, they were mine
for a couple of hours.
Sometimes I can get some
vouchers for a hotel
and that's even better.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So not too proud of what I do but
you know, we have our baser instincts and
sometimes you gotta follow 'em.
- [Mark] Yeah, there's many different ways
of looking at prostitution.
There are those that say,
no one's getting hurt.
It's okay.
Both parties agreed to it.
You'll see people taking
opposing sides on that.
- Well--
- It's a very complex topic.
- Yeah, I don't really want
to get into it but I think
if the woman's forced into it,
then it's wrong,
if she does it on her own...
- Yeah, that's (mumbles)
- And I don't think it's the
old days where you see guys,
the pimps, slapping around
the girls and dragging them in
and around and stuff like that (sniffs).
But unfortunately a lot
of them have drug problems
and
I don't really ask them
about their history but
it probably involves a
lot of abuse (sniffs)
and
they just need to get by,
they just need to do what
they need to do to get by.
- [Mark] Looking back at your life
and the tragedies that
you had to go through.
You've had jobs.
You've survived nicely.
What do you attribute that to?
What's your view on surviving?
- Well I've always liked to work
and I'd like to keep busy.
- [Mark] And that keeps you on track?
- Yep.
- [Mark] Despite the alcohol and?
- Yeah.
And if I got money and
nothing to do (sniffs),
then I go drink.
But if I got a job,
I'll go work all day and
then I'll get off of work
and drink and then go
to work the next day.
(sniffs loudly)
It did always help that
I've always worked in
bars and restaurants.
So it was acceptable for
me to be around alcohol.
And as a bartender
you would actually have
to taste the drinks.
So...
- [Mark] Have you ever had a girlfriend?
- Many.
- [Man] Long term.
- Yep.
- [Mark] A long-term girlfriend?
And those relationships were
successful, they were good?
- Yep.
(sniffs loudly)
You know, maybe it was my upbringing
but I never really wanted to have kids.
And I've actually had three
eight-year relationships with women
and they were great,
they were beautiful women,
I was lucky to be with them.
But kind of after like
the sixth, seventh year
they started saying, well,
when are we gonna get married,
when are we gonna get married?
And usually after like eight years,
I don't know what it is,
the 8 year itch or whatever,
you know, it was just,
I didn't wanna hold 'em back.
They wanted to have
kids, I didn't want to.
So,
they were some beautiful women.
- [Mark] All right, Frankie.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Good luck with
the rest of your life.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.